but remember the real problem we don't
know it's like a more full effective
image
of porn yeah too i mean they a lot of
the males are sort of like
good with them they like i i have found
back we're doing a love line a lot of
guys are like uh
i'd like a girlfriend but they're
they're a lot of work i'm okay i got
porn you know there's a little porn he
really kind of takes the edge off a
little bit for some of these kids i
don't know we don't
get that yet i don't though i'll tell
you the full effect it's not good
yes for me it has not been i know it's
like because i feel like these haunting
images in my head i think
and it just keeps me from like uh the
hunting image as far as the porn you
watch
yeah like it's fun with a girl no just
overall the images are fine in the
videos it's fine it is what it is
i don't think anybody's wrong for doing
it but i just think that then it affects
the way that i
could behave or think in a sexual way
because you're being influenced by the
porn you watch right that's the thing
you're expecting the girl to be like the
girls you're watching or
yeah or just you or just you don't think
of people
like you don't think like there's
somebody they do porn somewhere in this
building
you know sure i don't know where it is
but uh let me know because i've been
let's go
let's go look let's go take a look i
mean don't trust vlog
i've tried to look yeah nick knows and
he's almost
he's been suspended once let's just say
that just came back from suspension
uh but now i saw the other day i saw a
girl
walking into one of the offices right
and she had like a bag and she's got
different costumes kind of thing
and i'm like okay this is but but also i
noticed with this girl just by my glance
this is all judgment okay here's a young
lady she's tired she looks like she's
had a tough week or something
like just all the stuff you don't take
into account when it comes to porn like
porn you just see this finished product
yeah you're
you're i think if i would distill it
down what you're saying is you're
fearful that you will treat people like
objects not human beings but we do that
with everything
i think if it's fair to do it with just
porn we do that with our athletes too
right you look at them comment you're
millionaires just playing i've noticed
i'll tell you what we really have
opinions on really this gentleman the
corolla and i have been talking a lot
about this lately
yeah which is that what what has really
happened
is we're treat we treat people like
cartoon characters
like everyone in media has become a
cartoon that you're entitled to act out
on
cancel they don't really exist they're
just cartoons
and and it's really i think i think tv
started it like in the 60s with
gilligan's island
and it's become like pervasive now i
think there's a social media and
reaction because it's a reality
it's all everyone's a cartoon yeah but i
think so even though musicians are
cartoons
everybody's a cartoon everyone's cooking
and so it's like these aren't humans and
i think it's the same thing with
pornography i think that's what you're
getting on to
and it's causing us to behave in really
obnoxious ways
to humans who just happen to be in the
public sphere yeah really also look at
yeah
also i also like we should take into
consideration
that even prior to lockdown
which has only made things worse most
people
work way more hours than ever before and
are making less money than ever before
in comparison to how much everything
costs
every when i was growing up i'm not you
know you you were
in the same age bracket when we were
growing up even regular people
there was usually a one-income household
and you you were able to do it you had a
couple cars you go on vacation and my
friend's death were cops or
teachers and like they you could live
the life
it's not [ __ ] the way it is anymore
everyone's overworked overstressed
underpaid
and then you see people on tv and on the
internet who are rich
and seemingly not doing anything harder
than what you're doing
you're just like [ __ ] because you're
comparing yourself to them because now
if i'm you know a regular dude i or a
regular let's say i'm an 18 year old
girl i got on instagram i see kylie
jenner and her
wagon and her gucci purses now you are
when i was a kid and i got a cool car at
16
but then i see travis scott with his g
wagon now instead of comparing my car to
the kid who was up the street
i'm you're compared to the world now
right and that's people have this
resentment
and we all rose lead to narcissism we're
all we're all kind of narcissistic these
days everybody
yep some more than others but if you
really have a good dose of it like you
have some childhood trauma and stuff
you're going to express envy and envy is
extremely destructive emotion so you're
going to feel
she pisses me off she's got what i got
to bring her down to me i gotta bring
her down to the microphone
social media is a tool to help that
that's the canceling that's the mob
that's
everything and that's what we're into
these days and it's
really destructive it's it's again i
cannot warn people enough
that is a horrible instinct to be
jealous and envious
and knock people down that is the worst
that human beings have to offer
crab mentality but how do we how how is
there a way to curtail like
like should only certain like should you
have to
finish high school or do like what
should you have to do to get a social
media like
you know it almost seems like you get a
driver's license right which allows you
to act and behave with a vehicle
and but a social media account these
days is a vehicle it's like
you have people some anybody can be a
real person
to have your real name on there say
something on twitter and they'll cite it
on cnn or on
and could be life altering to the person
they're talking about like like
destroying their crazy
i put the i think a lot of people look
at it as like what can we do to get the
public to start doing this
i honestly think like maybe the
responsibility falls within people in
front
in the public eye maybe there needs to
be a little bit more transparency in the
fact that like
i think you're taught regardless of what
level of athlete
athletics politics or or um
entertainment
when you get into the public eye you
kind of create this idea it's this
unspoken rule that you pretend like it
doesn't affect you
just keep on trucking keep on trucking i
think the more and more
we expose the fact that athletes
politicians and and entertainers are
actually human beings that have moms and
dads and daughters and sisters and
brothers and we're like
no you know that really makes me feel
horrible and um i've been suicidal
and i feel fill in the blank because i'm
a human being
just like you i happen to be in movies
or i happen to play football for a
living
but i'm a [ __ ] human being with
feelings and uh maybe
i'm not saying you should but maybe we
should all rig you know why because
bullying face to face has a way of
working out
all kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
little kids are [ __ ]
all the way up through even teenage
years but what happens is
most people unless they're sociopaths
you act like an [ __ ] and every once
in a while you see how your behavior
affects another person you see
you look at it like oh man i really
[ __ ] hurt that guy's feelings when i
made fun of him in front of everybody or
in front of the football team and
somebody whoops you for being an [ __ ]
and i and i
and then or yes someone humbles you
reality has a way
of filtering out not only genetic things
but actually social things too
there's a filter where you go and you
grow and that's what creates evolution
the internet divorces and maturity and
selfhood and adulthood
and the internet divorces you from that
so i think maybe if if we in the public
eye
even real select you know all the way up
to a-list people like me on the z-list
all the way up to the a-list start to
say like
um you're right you're entitled to your
opinion you're entitled to your twitter
account
but uh you don't know me and you just
[ __ ] on me and i that really hurt my
feelings you know it does suck
i don't think that would stop it i don't
even maybe not maybe maybe not it might
be smart though my fear is also that
television is so cartoonizing of people
that they won't stop
they won't stop just continuing the
cartoon images and then people feeling
justified and acting out
this is the every time i i've had
conversations with 27 year olds so i go
look
you cancel people and they can't make a
living he goes at least
i had a guy go at least they're alive i
go whoa man
if you've been working on something for
50 40 years it's your career it's your
identity
and they now there's no possibility of
moving forward yeah so what
so what this is what's going on right
now it's like
oh my god you're destroying you they
haven't understood
that that's something inside him why
he's unhappy it's really
pleasure off them losing their game but
do they have that thing
inside of us i just wonder if the
mainframe of
feeling and of understanding that is
in a lot of people from our generation
if it's in these
if if it's not now in the hand and not
in the
i i think the compassion's there i think
what do you mean compassion's there
just like you know like you would say
like we we would see something we would
feel bad this would happen you would
in the world yes and now it's just like
i just wonder i start to wonder if the
same set of values or understanding or
empathy exists in younger people that it
did
this is getting in the way of developing
that rolling up the phone
but but that's my point though if you
took that away and did it in a more
real-life fashion here here's an example
why did i agree that gentleman i believe
his name is daryl i wish i could
remember his full name but yeah
he work at a um it's not that
daryl what does he look like red hair uh
no no he's a black gentleman
uh he doesn't work at that uh
you worked at the jiffy lube on ventura
boulevard no no i'm talking about okay
this guy he
i believe he's on rogan and he he goes
around hammond talking to
klansmen oh yeah and he's a black guy
and he uh he just spends time with him
he just steals
i'm not trying to change you i just want
to spend time with you and through
spending time with them
they change they he collects their
[ __ ] hoods and he comes and these
guys all come on they're like i don't
know what i was thinking
you know why because that's reality
there's empathy
and seeing someone and talking to
someone and experience someone you
literally
don't do that it's a weird facsimile of
doing it when you look at your phone or
you look at your computer screen
but it is not the same and until people
can realize that like
through human interaction it's the only
way moral and ethical things can be put
in place
laffy taffy ursula right there you're a
boy let me just say though there was a
famous
book in the 50s a guy went out and tried
to study how to deal with
uh discrimination and bias and stuff and
the book was called contact
that contact with though with another
person that's different than you
is what takes away all that [ __ ]
yeah and it's also but and the
one thing we don't see in the media
there's not the they never the truth
the full story isn't there it's like
that's the cartoon story
always the cartoon clickbait it's just
the same and it's also like
you know like and i think we have to
start looking at things not at like
i feel like it would be better if we
looked at things as a
as a people problem than as a like i
constantly feel like racism is always
blamed on white people you know
and i see a ton of racism that goes from
all different ethnicities and we talk
about it on here sometimes that there's
racism
across all walks and towards each other
that's our brain has a glitch and that
and racism is one of the glitches we
have to pay attention to so we don't
fall victim to it
[Music]